[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débats ils sont partout
dans notre alimentation de produits du
quotidien ou encore nos cosmétiques
ils ce sont les perturbateurs
endocriniens suspecté de modifier notre
système hormonal
ils peuvent avoir des effets négatifs
sur la croissance la fertilité et pire
être à l'origine de certains cancers
perturbateurs endocriniens comment les
éviter
c'est le débat du jour et pour y
répondre plusieurs invités autour de
cette table elle laetitia faurie et
pierre jean da cruz bonsoir bonsoir on
vous a tous les deux membres du
collectif cantine sans plastique de
louveciennes andré cicolella bonsoir moi
vous êtes président de l'association
réseau environnement santé à vos côtés à
corinne haricots bonsoir vous êtes
adjointe au maire de villepreux en
charge de l'environnement du
développement durable et de l'espace
public à villepreux qui a notamment
signé en cet après midi est la charte
ville et territoires sans perturbateurs
endocriniens dont on parlera évidemment
dans quelques minutes
alors les préoccupations liées aux
perturbateurs endocriniens ont
réellement émergé au début des années
2000 sa définition a seulement été
adopté il y a un an par les pays membres
de l'union européenne
andré cicolella vous êtes également
chimiste et toxicologue est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner une définition claire
tard perturbateurs endocriniens
c'est assez simple en fait comme le nom
l'indiqué ce sont des substances
chimiques qui perturbe fonctionnement du
système hormonal donc on les appelle
perturbateurs endocriniens
donc soit parce qu'ils vont interférer
sur l'âge la formation des hormones soit
sur le leti bib entre les hormones alors
parmi justement les perturbateurs
endocriniens les plus présents dans
notre vie quotidienne
on va retrouver notamment le baby
bisphénol a comme on trouvait notamment
dans les biberons les phtalates utilisés
dans les plastiques les parabènes qui
sont des conservateurs dans les
cosmétiques le triclosan ou encore les
pesticides
alors quels sont les risques pour la
santé c'est partir de
on a défini les perturbateurs
endocriniens c'est que l'impact
sanitaire est principalement liée à une
exposition pendant la grossesse
cette exposition a un impact sur la
santé de l'enfant du futur adulte et on
retrouve toutes les grandes maladies
chroniques aujourd'hui on est en
augmentation les cancers
hormono-dépendants cancer du sein cancer
de la prostate notamment les troubles de
la reproduction d'infertilité masculine
ou féminine les troubles du comportement
suspect à perturber les hormones
thyroïdiennes qui sont impliqués dans la
formation dans du cerveau et donc on a
des grands trous mais du point de vue
comme autisme notamment hyperactivité de
l'enfant et puis les maladies
métaboliques obésité diabète donc par
voie de conséquence mehdi
cardiovasculaires d'envoyer toutes les
grandes maladies aujourd'hui que l' oms
appelle épidémie mais ça le fasse une
épidémie mondiale de miley chroniques et
les perturbateurs endocriniens sont
l'une des causes pas la seule une des
causes majeures avec cette particularité
de générer un impact sur la personne
mais sur ses descendants donc ça c'est
l'élément déterminant qui fait qu' il
faut s'en préoccuper très rapidement
laissé sa folie et pierre jean d'âcre us
vous faites donc partie du collectif
cantine sont en plastique de lucian est
ce que vous pouvez nous présenter déjà
cette association
alors d'accord alors le collectif sans
plastique de lucian c'est un groupe
d'une vingtaine de parents des parents d
élèves de
des écoles primaires et maternelles de
la ville de louveciennes peut-être que
tu veux parler des dates que tu connais
moi le collectif alors initialement
c'était quelques représentants de
parents d'élèves qui sont retrouvés fin
lorsqu'ils ont su que la municipalité
allait mettre en place un nouvel appel
d'offres pour la restauration collective
et donc a commencé à travailler dessus
et a proposé d' avoir une approche de
partenariat avec la municipalité pour
essayer de travailler sur cette
restauration collective et sur cet appel
d'offres dont il ya une première réunion
publique qui a été à l'initiative de ces
quelques parents qui a été créé en
février 2018 et malgré les différents
échanges qu'on a pu avoir jusqu'en juin
on n'a pas eu d'avancées par la
municipalité en sachant que nous avons
une carte plastique alors c'est
peut-être un peu technique mais sur le
ciel on est sur ce qu'on appelle une
liaison chaude aujourd'hui on a cette
chance là c'est à dire que les repas
sont préparés le jour même et diffusé
ensuite dans les différentes écoles et
la muse péter souhaite aller vers une
liaison froide
donc ça veut dire que les repas pris à
l'extérieur exactement avec une
problématique liée au contenu de ces
repas qui sont bien souvent des
contenants en plastique et donc
diffuseur de perturbateurs endocriniens
que vous évoquez tous talents qu'est ce
qui vous a poussé à intégrer ce
collectif lavori mes inquiétudes pour la
santé environnementale de mon enfant
comme le dit pierre jean la préparation
aujourd'hui des repas elle est faite
dans la cantine centrale de l'ancien est
donc le jour même préparé dans des
contenants inerte donc en inox ou en
verre demain si cette prestation est
externalisée les repas déjà ce qu'on
fait pas préparé minimum 48 heures à
l'avancé puis
bc en température et stockés dans les
contenants en plastique puis livrés dans
des contenants en plastique et pire
encore réchauffé sur place dans les
annexes des cantines de l'école dans ces
mêmes contenants en plastique
donc même si on le sait il y a eu le
vote de l'amendement présenté par
lauriane rossi à l'assemblée nationale
en septembre qui rentre dans la loi plus
largement la loi galim avec
l'interdiction d'utilisation des
plastiques dans les cantines à horizon
2025 il y a un laps de temps à couvrir
pendant lesquelles les prestataires
externes ne vont pas pouvoir forcément
s'organiser remplaçant les contenants en
plastique par des contenants en verre ou
en inox etc ce qui aujourd'hui inquiète
beaucoup les membres du collectif
on reviendra sur / votre collectif je
vais juste donner la parole à corinne
rico puisque la ville de villepreux a
choisi de s'engager contre les
perturbateurs endocriniens
en signant donc cette charte c'est une
sorte de réseau environnement santé
alors concrètement cette charte ça veut
dire quoi mais concrètement déjà à
villepreux on avait déjà une démarche je
peux dire vertueuse comme disait
monsieur nous on a une cuisine centrale
donc déjà nos employés municipaux
travailler avec des contenants inox vert
mais on avait quelques livraisons en
contenants plastiques mais on a décidé
totalement vu qu'on a passé un nouvel
appel d'offres de limiter et de
totalement éradiquer ces contenants
plastiques et c'est une démarche que
l'on a depuis très longtemps parce qu'on
a travaillé aussi non seulement sur les
cantines mais aussi sur le zéro phyto
aussi sur la ville
puisqu'on a précédé aussi la
promulgation de la loi de 2018 nous on
est en zéro phyto depuis 2015 et donc
pour nous c'est un continue au niveau
d'environnement et c'est aussi non
seulement la santé humaine
c'est aussi la santé de l'environnement
et c'est aussi limiter la quantité de
déchets que l'on jette dans le ring et
une démarche d'achat responsable dans
tout à fait puisqu'on est passé aussi
depuis janvier 2019 sur du bio aussi
donc ce qui est un continue par rapport
à la santé des enfants et c'est vrai que
les perturbateurs endocriniens font
partie de tout ce panel que nous
voulions mettre en place andré cicolella
combien de communes en france ont signé
cette charte
si on intègre les communes engagées par
leur communauté d'agglomération à peu
près de 100 communes des grandes
communes paris strasbourg toulouse a
signé au mois de décembre
dijon l'image nanterre a signé aussi au
mois de décembre
donc quand partie de la région ile de
france première région
donc un conseil départemental cc du tarn
qui jamais aussi bien dans les abysses
et l'évier ou les régions qui qui font
sa démarche qui viennent vers vous c'est
vous qui allez ça à la fois c'est un
mouvement en un an
donc on sent bien qu'à une une volonté
de se saisir de cette question c'est une
attente aussi dans la population c'est
ce que vous rattraper ce qui nous
concerne villepreux on a fait la
démarche de contact est justement et de
signer cette charte le voir au mois de
janvier
donc le nom de cet important parce que
ça montre bien que voilà la prise de
conscience se fait que c'est sur ces
questions sur ces perturbateurs
endocriniens on peut obtenir des
résultats
justement vous parlez de prise de
conscience ça fait quand même des années
qu'on connaît les conséquences négatives
des perturbateurs endocriniens sur notre
santé pourquoi selon vous il n'y a pas
encore de loi kill et qui les
interdisait de bédouin on a obtenu la
première loi c'est à dire des biberons
voilà très symbolique en scène et la
france a étendu à l'ensemble de l'union
européenne la france a un jouer ce rôle
de leader au niveau européen on a obtenu
l'interdiction dans les contenants
alimentaires d'antan dans les boîtes de
conserve pour l'instant la france est le
seul pays au monde à avoir fait ça qu'on
va pas très bien pourquoi d'ailleurs ça
serait limité à la france puisque c'est
une source importante de contamination
donc mais ça n'est pas suffisant parce
que effectivement on a eu de multiples
sources et donc il faut qu'on a fait
acter c'est la stratégie nationale
perturbateurs endocriniens l'action
principe réduire l'exposition de la
population c'est consacre l'engagement
des collectivités locales est important
un des axes de la charte
c'est formation sensibilisation de la
population la commande et vous y faites
référence la commande publique
les commandes publiques on n'est pas
obligé d'attendre la réglementation on
transforme
voyez le la ville de paris a déjà une
demande moins à ses fournisseurs en
matière de produits d'entretien des
produits d'entretien sans alkylphénols
sont la grande famille des perturbateurs
endocriniens utilisés dans les polymères
c'est tout bénéfice pour la santé des
travailleuses du nettoyage pour la santé
de l'écosystème et je vais tout ça se
retrouve dans l'eau actuellement dans ce
cercle vertueux qu'il faut aujourd'hui
développer une eti safari et pierre jean
d'âcre us est ce que vous pensez qu'en
2019 les françaises et les français sont
suffisamment consciente ces risques je
crois que les français et les françaises
prennent de plus en plus conscience
notamment à travers des différents
reportages pour la petite anecdote la
loi qui est passé en septembre
elle est passée suite à pas mal de
reportages qui ont eu lieu pendant l'été
autour notamment des fameuses tortues
avec les plastiques autour et c'est tout
ce fameux continent plastique enfin
toutes ces images qui reviennent sans
cesse sur les réseaux sociaux on en
parle beaucoup
donc il ya eu aussi je pense du coup un
effet collatéral qui nous a aidés par la
loi c'était la démission nicolas hulot
qui a fait que la loi est passée en
septembre alors qu'elle avait déjà été
proposée avant l'été qu'elle avait été
refusée par le gouvernement
donc ça c'est aussi important toujours
au niveau de la loi et c'est là où on va
dans ce sens là c'est qu'au niveau de
l'europe y ait une loi qui a été votée
pour interdire tous les contenants en
plastique à usage unique
ça aussi on va dans le sens et on va
dans le sens de l'histoire donc
aujourd'hui maintenir des cantines
industrielles telles qu'elles existent
telles qu'elles existent notamment en
liaison froide je pense que ça ne va pas
dans le sens de l'histoire c'est un non
sens écologique etc ou un non sens au
niveau de la santé pour nos enfants
et puis pour nous tous vous parliez de
l'europe s'il ya notamment a beaucoup
parlé du glyphosate
si beaucoup de pesticides en fait ce
n'est pas tout les spécifique pour nommé
néanmoins à peu près un tiers des
pesticides sont des perturbateurs des
hormones thyroïdiennes nouvelle la
protection de la formation de notre
cerveau c'est quand même pas un enjeu
majeur marginal je veux dire c'est
majeur voilà bon c'est en priorité ce
sont ces pesticides qu'il faut éliminer
il ya des études d'ailleurs enfin je le
gardais de rebondir enfin moi j'ai
appris ça à lors de la conférence que
nous avions organisée sur le ciel sur
les perturbateurs endocriniens ou des
chercheurs se sont enfin il connaît et
notamment à des chercheurs avaient
expliqué qu'ils avaient une baisse de
cui et que ça avait été fait une baisse
de cuir au niveau des des personnes
à cause de ces ossements de conséquences
il y a beaucoup de français qui sont
conscients mais dans la mise en
application c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que il faut rentrer un
petit peu dans le détail par exemple ce
qu'on a appris à la projection
conférence que nous avons organisées
dans laquelle nous avons diffusé je vous
invite à le regarder le film de stéphane
horel la grande invasion sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens que par
exemple l'utilisation des poêles anti
adhésives et très nocif pour la santé
ce qu'elle relarguent justement des
perturbateurs endocriniens et donc c'est
dans ce genre de petit utilisation
quotidienne que les gens ne sont pas
encore sensibiliser et pas informés est
ce que justement vous personnellement
vous avez adopter de nouveaux
comportements ces dernières années moi
oui
- oui puisque moi je travaille au sein
de la petite enfance donc déjà très très
tôt moi j'ai déjà utiliser des biberons
en verre faire attention ne pas utiliser
du linge est par exemple utilisé du
coton mais ça c'est dans les pratiques
professionnelles
mais dans la vie quotidienne c'est vrai
qu' on essaie de regarder les
contenances idée des produits
cosmétiques etc
maintenant on voit sans paraben sans
mais c'est vrai que c'est compliqué pour
reste un argument marketing janvier tout
à fait tout à fait et c'est vrai que il
faut que les
et les grosses sociétés investissent là
dedans parce que c'est bon aussi pour
eux pour leur image et c'est bon pour la
santé
bien sûr mais si la forêt vous avez
changé vos habitudes peut-être en
cosmétique parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément également de perturbateurs
endocriniens qu'on retrouve dans les
cosmétiques mais j'ai commencé par
l'alimentation déjà j'ai jeté toutes
mais tous mes yeux doux mais anciens ou
les nouveaux tu peux revoir en plastique
un désolé pour la marque
j'avais plus de polycarbonate
oui mais du coup je suis passé aux
comptes non inertes à 100%
et puis effectivement les cosmétiques
avec des jeunes enfants on regarde je
n'utilise plus que des huiles végétales
qui sont sans risques voilà andré
cicollela vous c'est à dire à un moment
vous êtes vous avez lancé on va dire
c'est aux états lanceurs d'alertés sur
iphone sur les biberons studio disant
oui donc j'imagine que vous aussi vous
avez changé vos habitudes
oui merde tout ça se fait
progressivement si les plats prise de
conscience s'est lui aussi aux progrès
des connaissances scientifiques
aujourd'hui on est on est loin d'avoir
évalué toutes les substances dans 243
milles qui ont été mis sur le marché on
sait qu'on en a à peu près un millier
identifié mais plusieurs milliers
d'autres en fait c'est lent même temps
le problème est immense maintenant il
faut commencer par là où on peut agir et
c'est un éliminant ces grands groupes
notamment bisphénol talent a totalement
perfluorés puisque c'est ceux qui sont
présents effectivement dans les anti
adhésif
on a déjà des gains de santé
considérable considérable alors on
entend parler beaucoup d'oeufs bio est
ce que le bio finalement ce serait une
des solutions c'est face à ses
partenaires solutions puisque parfum
cycle les pesticides de synthèse sont
prohibés ceci étant vous mettez du bio
dans une boîte de conserve avec du
bisphénol c'est pas une bonne idée quoi
donc là il faut effectivement être
cohérent avec un froid le contenant
contenance et d'une source important
mais il faut agir le plus en amont
possible en fait alors évidemment il les
choix individuels mais on ne peut pas
laisser le choix entre une produits
toxiques la folie non toxique
il faut effectivement que les produits
soient non toxique par principe le
risque qu'un jour il sera possible de
supprimer entièrement les perturbateurs
dont
il ya là deux quotidiens oui mais pas
une pomme dans l'immédiat mais déjà déjà
la dizaine de grands groupes déjà c'est
tout à fait possible et sans que ce soit
forcément un bouleversement d'ailleurs
regardez le biberon à partir du moment
où la décision était prise dans les
trois semaines ne savait été appliquée
les boîtes de conserves c'est pareil
alors curieusement la france est le seul
pays mais on fait des boîtes de conserve
actuellement uniquement face en
missionnant uniquement pour la france
pendant absurde que sur les biberons il
ya plus de bisphénol a dans les biberons
mais il ya quand même des composants qui
sont toxiques dans les biberons en
plastique
la solution c'est du bronze ils scandent
lycée le lycée dont il est connu
meilleur il ya d'autres bestioles qui
ont remplacé le bisphénol a et sur
lequel on n'a pas de recul non plus
qu'ils sont de mémoire voilà leur ai
fait piloter cassé dans nos créations
donc ça a été le cas avec les papiers
thermiques était il ya eu cette
tentative de remplacer bpa par bpf
quant à l'absurde mais voilà non il ya
toujours l'enjeu c'est effectivement de
refonder réinventer l'activité des
industries chimiques
en intégrant cette divination sanitaire
qu'elle avait tendance à ne pas prendre
en compte qu'un peu absurde et voilà
c'est ça les comptes en jeu le prochain
congrès mondial de la chimie en en
juillet prochain
traiter de ces questions chimie société
je vais intervenir ont ce congrès voyez
donc les chaussures c'est aussi en train
de bouger à ce niveau là d'accord enrico
donc ville prête à signer aujourd'hui
cette charte est ce que il va y avoir
aussi une suite est ce que vous allez
adopter d'autres comportements peut-être
ensemble à la mairie mme je pense qu'on
est déjà bien virtuel c'est notre
comportement oui toute façon
on va travailler aussi avec des sociétés
de ménage pouvoir quels sont les
produits qu'ils utilisent aussi parce
qu'on a des sociétés extérieures qui
viennent travailler qui viennent
nettoyer nos écoles etc
on a déjà travaillé avec les avec la
halte garderie qui qui est qui dépend de
notre de notre commune on travaille
régulièrement avec eux et toute façon ce
sont des personnes qui se tiennent au
courant de ce qui se passe et qui sont
très très conscient de des problèmes
qu'il peut y avoir au sein de la petite
enfance et au niveau des écoles aussi
dans cette émission touche bientôt à sa
fin on va faire juste un tour de table
pour pour conclure sur sur ce débat
andré cicolella je voulais c'est la
parole écoutez moi je je ce que je
constate c'est effectivement qu'il ya un
bon citoyen qui se développent et ça
c'est important c'est la prise de
conscience que le grand enjeu c'est
effectivement faire reculer toutes ces
grandes maladies chroniques
voyez un chiffre qui me revient à
l'esprit mais le cancer aujourd'hui
c'est une personne surtout on est
content on est arrivé à cette situation
et rognons considérées par eux quasiment
ça comme normal disent tout à fait
anormal le l'asthme de l'enfant première
pathologie chez l'enfant de cinq à dix
ans le lien que les perturbateurs
endocriniens est avérée on peut faire
reculer l'infertilité aujourd'hui un
couple sur quatre coups sûrs cinq ça peu
près ça de l'estimation basse qualité du
sperme on a perdu les deux tiers de
leurs espérances
en 50 ans mais tout ce qui touche tous
les indicateurs clignotent
donc il est temps d'agir c'est à la fois
pour notre santé mais la santé aussi des
générations futures c'est ça notre
responsabilité et le mouvement qui se
dessine et montre enfin la prise de
conscience sont faits mais titia faurie
pour conclure merci d'ailleurs
on le voit en malgré le cadre
réglementaire
qui se met en place européen national et
lois qui sont votées il ya encore un
gros travail de sensibilisation à mener
on le voit aujourd'hui nous dans notre
commune puisque on attend la décision de
la mairie pour
[Musique]
pour ne pas transformer la préparation
des repas aujourd'hui et pouvoir garde
de garder une préparation des repas ce n
est sans danger pour la santé
environnementale de nos enfants et
d'ailleurs nous avons lancé une pétition
ce sujet c'est chacun veut y contribuer
sur mesopinions.com comme voilà sur foot
+ cantine semaine dans la barre de
recherche bien on vous retrouve aussi tu
raillé un site internet une page
facebook
quand une semaine de toussaint voilà
c'est la fin de ce set 8 débat merci
d'avoir été présent tous les quatre
merci à vous d'avoir suivi ce débat on
se retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro à très bientôt
[Musique]